تحديد ووعيد مؤكد واجهته رابطه المشجعين
المتشددين او الالتراس في المنتخب
الارجنتيني لاي لاعب يتسبب باصابه النجم
اليونال ميسي قبل بدء مونديال 20 22
الالتراس الارجنتيني اكد في بيان انه من
يتعمد اصابه ميسي قبل المونديال سيكون في
خطر الاطراف قالوا في بيانه من ميسي هو
الوحيد القادر على تحقيقه حلم المونديال
الغائب عن خزائن فريق التانجو لنحو سبعه
37 عاما ويعد المونديال القادم الاخير لان
النجم الارجنتيني الذي يعمل في تحقيق حلم
الظفر بالبطوله العالميه الاغلاق خصوصا
وانه سيلعب اخر مونديال له مع بلوغه السن
الخامسه والثلاثين
[موسيقى]
يبقى الحدث الابرز والاهم عالميا قادم
المونديال وجنون كره القدم كيف يمكن تفسير
اليوم ظاهره تهديد اللاعبين جماهيريه يعني
التقرير الولد من لحظات بفسر كل شيء وعطا
ممثلين كثير كثير كبار واحد منهم ادى الى
الحاسه ماساويه للاعب اسكوبار في عام 1994
بمباراه فريق كولومبيا ومنتخب امريكا
بس يعني الفتره الاخيره ما عم نشوفها عم
يوصل لهدرجه من الخطوره صحيح
دوري ابطال بس يعني اكثر من هيك يعني
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
او على تويتر همم اليوم صار صار نصعب
الحصول على رقم اللاعب الشخصي وفي حال
الحصول
بعض الاشخاص على رقم اللاعب الشخصي بتصور
لازم يغيره تلقائيا طيب هذه الظاهره عبر
التاريخ يا جورج هناك لاعبين دفعوا بالفعل
حياتهم ضحيه العنف الجماهير العائد للهوس
الكروي لو نتحدث ما اصل هذه الروح العنيفه
يا جورج
هذه روحي اكثر شيء موجود بامريكا الجنوبيه
لانه هناك همم كره القدم هو هو دين
بالنسبه لهم يعني اهم شيء اليوم يعني اذا
رحنا على البرازيل اذا رحنا على الارجنتين
قال يعني المتنفس الاساسي للشعب هناك كره
القدم عشان هيك تشوف الناس مهوسه همم
بالفوتبول ومهوسي ومتعلق كثير من
اللاعبيننا وهمم عنده حلم دائما انه
المونديال او الفوز او الفوز بالبطولات
حتى بتصير هناك بس يعني كاس ليبرتادوريس
بين الفرق اللي بتجمع بين همم البرازيل
الارجنتين وكولومبيا وغيره وغيره بتشوف
حضور جماهيري والصوت الجماهير غريب بعيد
عن اوروبا هناك صخر كبير هناك حماس كبير
بالملعب وهذا الشيء بعود الى التعلق
الجمهور بها اللعب همم الى حد الهوى وشفنا
شو صار من همم من احداث يعني واليوم مثلا
بالارجنتين ميسي مطالب يرجع يعيد ويكرر
انجاس دييغو ارماندو مارادونا الاخير بعام
1986 وقياده الارجنتين الى الفوز بكاس
العالم وهذا الشيء بشكل ضغط كثير كبير مع
النجم الاجنبيك